The Joe Rogan Experience FDX
that FDX thing is crazy because so many
people were spokespeople for it is
having a rough [ __ ] that didn't break up
his marriage
I'm telling you she was like oh we
better split her split ties right now
there Tommy because it's about to get
ugly
but fortune favors the Bold who's that
huh that was oh my God Matt Damon for
which which Bitcoin
who cares uh I forget which one crypto
fortune favors the Bulls
I think they own the Staple Center when
he was he was comparing it to people
going to the moon and I'm like bro
opponent they named it well of course
they were talking about Jane corrects me
real quick for you
I said they don't own it we can't have
three different conversations going on
kids when they were talking about uh
somebody said kids he was doing that
commercial where he's like comparing it
to like space travel
yeah talking about innovators
groundbreakers look at this telling all
these [ __ ] barely making people Matt
Damon fans who almost adventured who
almost achieved
But ultimately
for them it proved to be too much he's
telling regular people to be Galileo
yeah these [ __ ] losers we're talking
about people who embrace the mode that
guy's not embracing mode that guy's a
crazy [ __ ] climbing up Glacier that's
not smart this is cheesy the Wright
brothers
mere mortals oh
funny those guys admitted flight and
grind them out and they're like
gay guys guys
it's true there's four simple words that
have been whispered by the Intrepid
since the time of the Romans
fortune favors the brave
wow it's not really braved by crypto
well it is now now it is yeah but when
something like that FTX thing goes down
where you watch billions of dollars just
disappear yeah I lost a fortune
fortune favors Braves that would you be
doing that with that well I'm just
saying I lost a lot of money did you
lose a lot of money yeah
yeah you really did put money I did I'm
trying to tell you oh I thought you were
joking no no I lost a ton how much I
don't want to get into numbers here it'd
be impolite how much but uh enough to
disturb in the that was the first time I
checked I lost like 15 grand in the tens
like this year yeah I thought it was the
right thing to do I saw the commercial
dude I was never gonna take it out of
there so people are suing Larry David
yeah it was just a commercial because he
did a commercial for them
they're suing there's a class action
lawsuit I think it involves uh
find out what it does Tom Brady Larry
David they're saying why'd you tell us
to do this I don't know that it's going
through yet I think they've talked about
it so some people are saying but then
there's also the people that are like
where's my money yeah and this guy is
just gonna go to some New York Times uh
thing that they're doing this week right
tomorrow all right today there you go
yeah they've got some New York Times
thing where people are speaking Yeah and
he's going to go up there hey I [ __ ]
up
okay
marching positions opened with that's
probably gonna be very boring
through his head of that over attack yes
uh this year when they shut down this
guy's a weirdo that means you know I I
think it was over collateralized
um positions
um but positions that involve
substantial size and substantial US
dollar size
this is nuts it looks like Oz
right I don't like it don't look fast
you couldn't get this guy a better
plants put the headphones on so you can
hear this guy all right no it's bizarre
was consistent
um the dashboard what this could be
um I would go yay what are you talking
about foreign
but you would agree yeah much look at
him shaking we connected
um I think he just shakes of FTX
International bro he's tricky then
previously understood
yeah look at the pupils are huge I mean
given the size of the position I think
it was like it's not in intention it was
in effect I tied together substantially
more than I would have ever wanted it to
be this is weird
um and the same original people but most
of the remaining nexuses you said have
dropped nexuses
I know the people from Alameda decently
well almost as if you don't know what's
happening there
and there isn't like a large amount you
know of ways remain that we are actively
working together
anything like that Alameda is a wholly
separate entity they're different
offices like different principal offices
we don't have any shared Personnel we're
also not the same company we not all are
under the same corporate umbrella or
anything like that and yet it seems
like Alameda people were living in the
same Penthouse where you may very well
be right now I guess it seems that way
doesn't have an [ __ ] yeah right um uh
most of Alameda was not uh it was not
there uh I I don't live there now but uh
I'm not there now I have not uh lived
there
um but you know I did live with with uh
one or two members of Alameda for a
little while
um and I'll also say that you know as I
was you know earlier this summer looking
at the relationship and this is
fine
exactly I can't recognize my own and so
when I was listening
that had fallen off
in 2019 something like two percent oh
this year but in terms of positions and
balances
refractions
I'm just studying his mannerisms yeah
he's tweaking out like Hitler tweaking
out yes
very Under Pressure also he's the most
pressure tweaking from that for sure
imagine billions of dollars they're
missing gone yeah that's live dude he's
getting billions billions of dollars and
you know they're they've got like all
these tweets and [ __ ] different things
that they've said in different
statements that he said about his
company that just seemed to be untrue
live updates and stuff he was saying
during it too uh but the thing that he
was just discussing there was this
another company called Alameda and
apparently they gave and they'd move 10
billion dollars over to Alameda and they
don't know like how that was done or
what it was done but it was like a
company that was connected to them
initially he lied about it and said he
didn't work with those people and they
were all banging each other
yeah
that was last week
he's gone yeah they had he lived in a
house with like 10 people they were all
banging each other influence every time
Bitcoin every time and they were all
doing amphetamines this lady who was one
of them was on she wrote on Twitter this
was like one of the top people at his
company wrote on Twitter that after you
what was the exact quote we talked about
it yesterday
find out find her exact I don't want to
paraphrase because I'm high yeah you
know you're on shrooms when the screen
is all funky
I feel like I watch things and they're
not even there
I know I could just picture things
happening so he's gonna Cry he's going
down it looks like fried is [ __ ] damn
yeah he looks like he's [ __ ] the way
that wasn't great I didn't understand
one word I don't remember freed rather
is [ __ ] nothing like regular
amphetamine used to make you appreciate
how dumb a lot of normal non-medicated
human experiences this is in April 2021
and this is like that's a reaction we
just saw she was one of the top dogs
over there she was one of the top people
over there and they were all banging
each other every time on speed banging
each other making figure out a way to
take the money away from the people I
don't know what happened man but whoa
yeah that was chamberlains 40 million
dollar Penthouse and now it's listed for
sale all the dorks are [ __ ] in this
school
[ __ ] it in there bro they thought they
were in a movie great bro
[Laughter]
part of me's rooting for them part of me
is like I wish they weren't stealing
money I wish it wasn't a Ponzi scheme
yeah man I wish because if it wasn't a
Ponzi scheme easy
if it wasn't a Ponzi he wouldn't succeed
so right it's a chicken of the egg but
that guy either goes school shooter or
he's just gonna make crypto